[Music]
hey what's up party people welcome to
another star studded edition of honest
trailer commentaries where we watched
all the best picture nominees so you
don't have to
and you definitely didn't this year uh
i'm here with lon i'm here with danielle
we're gonna give our uh mini reviews our
behind the scenes thoughts on every
uh film we covered in this trailer we'll
show you some cut jokes
um we'll answer questions and comments
from viewers like yourselves so keep
them coming in the chat
and we'll tease you with next week's
honest trailer it should be a fun one
um hello welcome uh danielle
uh elon what do you think of the uh crop
of best picture nominees this year
overall
um you know uh it it loses something
because i have like a whole tradition
where you get together and you watch
them all
and you do that thing so i think it kind
of loses something without
the camaraderie of that and just kind of
watching it from home
um but sound of metal i really genuinely
thought was a really really good movie
um that might be my favorite out of
all of the movies with sound of metal i
might because i watched it first
that's always a possibility um but yeah
you know it's
uh it's interesting when you have sort
of a
a lower um amount of movies that we were
even getting
tenet not really being around here i
maybe kind of surprised me but maybe not
i don't know
oh tenant truther lon what do you think
is this representative of the year's
best movies or
nah uh it's it's i mean i think it's
it's like a it's like a pretty good year
like i think
most of the movies on this list i think
are are at least
above average to to quite good and then
it does have some of my favorite like
i would say judas and the black messiah
menari
and nomad land and sound of metal like
those four
i i think it's hard to make the case
that those four are legitimately among
the best movies
of last year or at least like american
movies that were released like
eligible in sort of that parameter um
so yeah and and only you know only one
or two sort of stand out to me
as like i i might not have put that up
for best picture no
glaring like i don't feel like there's a
green book this year that feels like
what is that doing there
um maybe trial of the chicago's i was
going to say that's my green book this
year
that's on the bubble but i think i i
think that's still a i think that's more
defensible i agree that's the bubble
case this year but
um i also thought and i know you know
listen
i get that i'm a 40 year old white man
so
feel free to disregard this take but
uh i didn't i didn't love promising
young woman i
i liked it promising young women felt to
be like the kind of movie that would
come and go
and then in like three or four years
somebody would be like
hey did you ever see that weird
promising young woman it's actually
pretty good and you'd watch it you'd be
like
oh yeah this kind of flew under the
radar it doesn't feel like a best
picture
kind of thing to we'll cover that when
we get to that section i
i think to me the chicago 7 is the only
green book of the bunch
um i would replace it with either the
five bloods
another round or first cow those are the
three things that were in my best
picture list but didn't make the uh
the finals and we will be doing our
annual uh if we were the academy video
so so stay tuned for that one
but let's talk about every uh yeah a
little teaser every um
we'll talk about every movie as we watch
it so let's uh let's hit it with the
honest trailer for the oscars 2021
one of my favorite traditions
because otherwise i wouldn't have these
things
[Music]
yeah it's some of them it's it's like
you gotta like
work for the oscars the annual award
show
for the year's best movies in a year
where no one could go to the movies
but since nothing can stop hollywood's
biggest stars from giving awards to each
other
here are your honest nominees for this
year's best picture
prepare for a film about injustice
political activism
and social movements that couldn't have
come at a more timely moment
oscar season it's the academy awards of
protests and as far as i'm concerned
it's an honor just to be nominated
in aaron sorkin's first film to give the
finger to historical truth
since well his last four movies
featuring borat's wackiest accent yet
over the course of ten days the
government called 37 witnesses
eddie redmayne's third or fourth
wackiest accent yet whether we're giving
permits or not
we're coming and the guy from succession
doing an impression of cheech and chong
at the same time it's a tom collins i
know it's kind of a country club drink
but they're delicious
so get inspired for more of the
fast-paced sorkini speechifying that
could maybe almost change someone's mind
about something
if they were already open to the ideas
in the first place and you caught them
on a good day
chicken soup for the liberal soul
all right pause now look
i don't know i'm not a historian nor did
i live through these events
and it turned out that there are uh a
lot of things that were
kind of surprising like oh the judge
really was that biased and that
uh angry and and the cops did riot that
day
but in watching it i'm like this is
[ __ ] none of this happened the way
that he's presenting it
and then in looking through the the
documents or the articles written about
like
this is how it went down like it's not
how it happened he turned this actual
thing into like a play into a west wing
episode and it was just so obnoxious and
i preemptively hate it so much
because it's going to win best picture
uh thoughts
uh the one thing that he totally
fictionalized that he made up for the
movie
there's a moment where they're walking
in a bunch of the guys who are on trial
are walking into the courtroom and
somebody whips an
egg at jerry rubin who jeremy strong is
playing and he
catches it and he's like hey man i
couldn't and that's such a dumb
weird thing you're like well that must
have happened there's there's no way you
would just make that up
that must be a thing that just weird
happened that you were like i got to put
that movie no
i'm sorry he made up a whole bunch of
stuff he made up the the
uh fed who uh jerry rubin um right oh
i'm not falling
in love with no i'm not saying that's
the only thing he made up i'm saying i
think every other thing he made up like
i get from a storytelling
perspective why you'd make that thing up
like it's easy danielle's out
danielle's just she couldn't hear
anymore she's it's like it's easier for
him to do whatever
why would you make up the egg thing it's
so weird
and i don't even think it's possible
like if i threw an egg at you and you
reached up to catch it would just
explode in your hand wouldn't it
sure i mean it was an impressive feat of
egg catching if that was indeed a real
egg well it doesn't even yeah it doesn't
even look real in the movie the moment i
saw it i was like well that must be real
because you'd never write something
bizarre like that if it didn't happen
sure you would if you're aaron sorkin
maybe but just
making the the the hero of this story um
you know tom hayden like the most a
fictionalized
super moderate version of tom hayden and
the the federal prosecutor with a heart
of gold it just tells you exactly where
sorkin's sensibilities lie which is the
west wing which is like
if we all just move towards the center
we're all just that's where
everything good happens like i mean
look i think the problem is and it's my
problem with a bunch of like i like some
sorkin but i think that he's so enamored
of the speechifying and the politics and
like
here's my take on this historical moment
that he just like he forgets to
he forgets to make it a compelling
narrative about these guys and it just
becomes like you said like a
a play where we're here to like listen
to all of these
great well-written speeches and like
hear all of these ideas but then at the
end it doesn't really
add up to much i think it also has the
uh it's really unfortunate that it was
reformed for
trial of chicago seven there was
released in the same year as mangrove
the lead-off film of
small acts the steve mcqueen collection
that's on amazon
the first film in that collection is
called mangrove and it's also
based on a true story that's also about
a bunch of
guys who led a protest that then turned
into a clash with police who were also
arrested for inciting a riot
and it's it's just it's in london and
it's the west indian community there
instead of
hippies in in chicago but it's just it's
a much more compelling and personal take
and also judas and the black messiah
also a more personal take yeah on the
same side the individual stakes of these
kinds of things instead of just as
a historical sort of panorama
and i think both of those were more
effective yeah it just felt like a a
massive circle jerk and
um and maybe it won't win because um uh
i did
ask my dad who was like you know living
through these events like
what do you think of this and he's like
this does not pass the smell test this
is not how it happened or what it felt
like to be around there
so so there you go so maybe i think i
feel like
nomad land has a lot of the momentum
that that if i was gonna
place money on it i think that's yeah i
think that's our winner yeah could be
well i don't know what happened to
danielle um but we've got so many movies
left i'm sure
i i hope she's well and she'll be back
for uh the next one let's keep going
i hope i didn't drive her away
experience the moving story of black
panther leader fred hampton
snitch in an intimate portrayal of the
relationship between this backstabbing
[ __ ]
and jesse plemon's latest white boy you
don't want to mess with
leaving audiences with about as much
knowledge of the black panther movement
as forrest gump
sorry how to fight in the middle you're
a black panther party that still
definitely deserves a best picture
nomination but it's kind of sting that
defy bloods got snubbed while spike
lee's literal film student got in
you do know you can honor more than one
black director at a time right
at least nominee delroy lindow you
cowards
yeah pause i mean i didn't have much to
say about jews and the black facade
it's really good i wish there was more
on fred hampton and
and do centering it so much through the
lens of this uh
undercover cop i don't know uh for
somebody who again
doesn't know anything about real history
uh i wanted to know more
um and i didn't really care about uh
lakeith's character as much
um but it was like a good window into
the power dynamics of the
the feds and and the party at the time
but i like it more as a springboard to
talk about the five bloods which i
really enjoyed
and i guess just came out too early for
them to re
remember it or recognize it yeah i mean
i i don't know i
i love the five bloods five plus
definitely i think should have been up
for best picture as well
um yeah i think i think it definitely
came out early and that was part of it
and i think it was also
like so many spikey things it's so
ambitious it's taking on
so much and i think it's just like
overwhelming for some people like
that experience i i really enjoy those
kinds of movies but i know that
it can be frustrating for some viewers
if you're if you're really enjoying it
on the level of this war movie adventure
then you're bummed out that he's
interrupting it for like documentary
style
segments where you look at the history
of what's going on and fill in the
context if you're enjoying that stuff
then you're like oh but i don't care
about the these guys and the camaraderie
and you know
like there's so many different elements
going on that he i think is sort of
bringing together in this really
interesting you know
i mean i like the stew i like the the
collage the the hodgepodge like
throwing everything at the wall um like
uh i felt the same way about chiraq a
few years ago i thought that was one of
the best films of the year that totally
got overlooked
um but uh yeah it reminds me of some
ways of what oliver stone was doing in
the 90s with stuff like jfk
and nixon where that also kind of rubbed
some audiences the wrong way but i think
it's like
exciting and you kind of never know
where you're going to jump around to
next
but i mean there's no other way to say
it at least nominate del roy lindo you
cowards because he
like say what you will about his the
style of filmmaking and the movie and
the plot or subject matter or anything
but
man that was an amazing performance like
start to finish
no i mean i i bought i bought the super
yaki shirt like yeah i i feel very
strongly of delroy
but i mean he's he's also he's one of
those guys that
doesn't get the big nominations isn't
isn't top of mind when people are
rattling off
the best actors of his generation and
yet clearly is one of the best actors of
his generation you could go back to like
get shorty and clockers and so many
like really memorable iconic
performances from that guy
and it just it really felt like not only
is this an
all-timer into five bloods but it's just
time
it's just yeah it's time um yeah and
just i i recommend everybody watch the
film if you haven't just
just for him alone um the black messiah
also a great film and i i thought
does a does a very powerful job of yeah
making these
larger than life characters real it's
yeah i've you can read
the books and see the films about fred
hampton and the black panthers and
here's what they stood for and
you know the berets and the guns but
then you see this and you're like it's
about
the the man and how he was only 21 and
and
like his world and the relationship
between those guys and i found that
really compelling yeah
but alas we are ostensibly a comedy
program and i just didn't have too much
to say about it so
let's just i mean it's hard to it's hard
to mock it's these are serious these are
serious topics folks
all right let's go on to the next one
from the colossal castles
to the bustling boulevards of boys town
all of hollywood is in the tank for mank
that compelling kane chronicle from
fight club front man fincher has
everyone talking from film historians to
film festival programmers
heck even film preservationists want
hanky-panky from mr manky
don't have intimate knowledge of old
hollywood history we'll hit the books
junior
any man jack who doesn't know their
shearers from their cells next is gonna
get all flipped around before you can
say irving j
thalberg oh brother gary oldman is the
cat's pajamas as the man who put the
mink in herman j
mankowitz a fella who was half the
actor's age when this all took place
stop by the trailer for another layer of
powder mr old man you'll get there plus
there's the lovely lily collins as bank
secretary who takes notes on all of his
opinions
and the amazing amanda seyfried as
mank's friend who listens patiently to
all his opinions
and the transcendent tuppence middleton
as menk's wife who sits quietly while he
has his opinions
great job james maybe you'll get some
opinions of your own one day
after all it's tinsel town where dreams
come true so grab your most patient
grandparent for a retro revisionist
roller coaster ride of righteousness
relevance and rebuke that may look like
a classic film that unfolds with all the
aimless filler of a modern day 13
episode netflix show
take that mr punisher you've just been
manked what good
prank mankers
oh that was now almost unedited uh uh
elon harris diatribe
um channeling scoops mcgee i believe on
that one
a powerhouse vocal performance from john
i love how that one
all came together and the quick update
of course uh danielle's internet has
gone down and she is on the phone with
spectrum so
the spectre of bastards you know
spectrum full spectrum bachelor
oh my god um so hopefully that will get
resolved but don't hold your breath
um anyways mank um
love i love mank but i think at sort of
an ironic distance
just because it is so like impenetrable
to anybody who doesn't
care about 1930s hollywood yeah it's so
weird because on one level like
obviously
dave fincher a bright boy knows what
he's doing and
he his ability to take a you know make a
modern film but in this 30s
style it's really cool like he's got a
lot of mastery of that
era of filmmaking and how a 30s movie
might look in the shots and the sets
i i really enjoyed it on that level but
unlike a 30s movie
this is just like it's really aimless
and it really seems to like
not know exactly what its take on mank
is and who mank is and so the journey
just feels like really sloppy and like
that's a thing that in a 30s movie would
be like
down they had that down do like a
science it would be like a well-oiled
machine
you'd know exactly what bank's goal was
the whole time and
yeah it just felt like um no effort to
like
endear mank to us or make us see things
make us you know yeah i don't need to
love mank i don't need to like make but
i need to understand mink
right and he's actually he's just want
to know mank better
yeah that's it and i i don't i don't i
don't feel like he's a character that's
compelling it feels like a loud
drunk with a lot of opinions he's a
drunk who wanders around you know nice
looking grounds and pontificates
it's like it's like david fincher made
avatar but about 1930s hollywood he's
really like the sam worthington just
this guy who takes you through this
other world and like oh look over there
it's uh william randolph hearst and oh
over there it's this is dave no sells
nick like
yeah i don't care you cared if you don't
you don't right it's like it's
it yeah it's sort of fun on that level
but then you're like
there's a scene towards the end where
amanda seyfried who they're
they're all all the actors are are good
it's not a knock on any of that but
amanda seyfried comes to see mank uh
she's marrying david
she's trying to they're old friends and
she's trying to talk him out of making
this project that he's currently working
on
not only for selfish reasons but because
she knows it'll ruin him
and uh you're like halfway through the
scene you're just like i should i should
care
like i this or this this is emotional
these are two old friends
she's like reaching out to him like on a
personal level and i i just i just don't
it's just sitting there on screen and i
mean you also you brought up a good
point in this section it's like
by doubling his age the the specter of
ending his career doesn't
hit home as hard cause like this is like
a 60 70 year old man
and he should retire and when he was
writing this script mike was like
32 i think yeah like earlier beginning
of his career like
up and coming as opposed to on the tail
end and that's not a rummy yeah that's
not a thing gary oldman can just like
fit like he's brilliant nobody's
knocking gary oldman but
like i don't know if he can act his way
out of that scenario it just seems
unfair to him
yeah um so a a flawed but fun one i
i i think like i go oh wow i didn't know
upton sinclair ran for governor like it
was full of moments of like oh wow
that's
interesting it's kind of a tour through
a period of history that i didn't know
again didn't know much about um so i
appreciate it on that level and yes
david fincher knows how to frame a scene
there's lots of beautiful
imagery see it on the biggest screen you
can which is going to be your television
um uh and yeah full of good performances
but i do think it's kind of like too
impenetrable to to a
crossover to be win best picture this
year but we'll see it's got a good story
behind it of like oh his dad wrote it
and he's like yeah
and the oscars they like people who make
movies love movies about movies you know
like they love
honoring the cinema and so like the
artist
yeah it is a movie about the power of
movies and so that's always a thing
all right what's next that's also fun to
say reuben
a hardcore rocker who loses his hearing
which is a nightmare scenario for a
musician
and i guess pretty bad for drummers too
watch him go through the five stages of
griez
with an extended stop in anger
yeah take that donut you've had it too
good for too long
in this shoe-in to win all of the sound
awards and continues the whiplash
tradition
of angry drummer movies that deserve
best picture but won't win
and hey at least riz ahmed is the first
muslim to ever get a best actor
nomination
so we're still hitting these firsts
after almost 100 years at the oscars huh
good for us
yay def jam
so yes there's been a flood of um
actually people uh
mentioning mahershala ali's win for best
supporting actor
we say best actor and that's what we're
basically say specifically
the best category specifically yeah
so there you go um yeah this was my
favorite movie of the bunch uh maybe my
favorite of the year i
i don't know i think that it's it worked
on two
kind of parallel levels for me one was
this kind of exploration of
the deaf community and just the uh
something i knew nothing about and was
kind of this beautiful
introduction to a way of living and
being okay with
uh uh with this affliction or whatever
however they frame it it's it was kind
of a beautiful story of
acceptance and uh and how these people
live and and thrive and adapt
uh to life circumstances and then the
other level was like
i feel like not to take away from that
but the
parallel to our own lives is like this
is somebody who's had to deal with
uh a change in their circumstances that
they did not wish and is very disruptive
and i think we can all relate to that uh
this last year
like and it's about you know you can
rage against it or you can kind of come
to terms with it and i thought that it
was kind of a beautiful story of
of self-acceptance and just acceptance
of the world at large and
uh and spoke to me on that level and the
music and sound design was really really
cool and it's got a great performance
so that's my that's my case for uh
best best film of the year for um i keep
wanting to call it death gym for sound
event
yeah i mean it's a difficult needle to
thread with a story like this because
it's got to feel
authentic and specific to what it's
about you know it's about a real thing
like people go deaf and there's this
deaf community and
this really happens to people every year
and so it has to feel like it's telling
that story and it's not
purely universal and like i thought you
know riz ahmed and paul racey who i
assumed when i was watching this
uh paul racing plays the guy who's like
the mentor at the
deaf community where he goes to live uh
i assumed
that was a real guy like a nomad land
they found a real guy who runs like a
commune for deaf people and they got him
to be in the movie
he's a character actor i've seen him in
other stuff he's been in a bunch of tv
shows
that's incredicity of that
performance and they did surround him
with other deaf actors who are playing
the other people living in that
community
um so it does it passes the smell test
and you do feel like you're getting
insight into what it's specifically like
to lose your hearing
later in life but it also has to work on
the level of the universal which is just
like what you were saying like
you if it does relate to being
quarantined for a year i felt like
not having deafness but other health or
medical or mental health issues
i think you could certainly relate to
that feeling of like these things are
interrupting you in the prime of your
life and the flow of your life and you
don't have
time to like accommodate all of these
and compartmentalize all these different
things
so yeah it's it's not it this movie
makes it look easy to do but it's really
hard to do that to tell
a story that's working simultaneously on
both of those levels and
it pulls it off incredibly it's very
very powerful especially though
i don't want to say what happens with
the final sequences
yeah it's so good um yeah same with
whiplash although they
really the only dna they share is angry
drummer at the center of it all
um and i do think i like whip i think
this is a
i think this is a better certainly a
movie with a healthier perspective than
whiplash
yeah whiplash but i was i thought well i
i i put it
a maybe 1b next to birdman i do think
birdman deserved
uh deserved its best picture that year
i'm gonna get yelled at but i i really
like birdman i was a big bird man well
yeah one a one b
i think we're aligned um but the uh uh
yeah i assumed when i watched this that
it was a true story or based on the
writer director's
hearing loss or something but no this
was just kind of pulled out of the ether
i thought that was so incredible um and
yes uh paul racy's character
uh on one sense you you assume he's
based on a real person uh but on the
other side isn't there always someone in
rehab who's like
a ponytailed white guy with some tattoos
who sees some [ __ ]
yeah but yes but like you know
it meets up it met up with my
expectations in that way that it felt
like they were pulling something off
and then when i looked that guy up and i
was like it wasn't only that he oh he's
just an actor he's
just doing a performance but it was like
oh i've seen him and stuff he's been in
a bunch of stuff that i've seen and it
was
just you know he made me made me believe
it in the moment
well you know i love this movie but it
did ruin um
those uh turning on your cochlear
implant for the first time youtube
videos
for that that was those hit different
now
um so anyways if you haven't seen it now
you're suspicious
you're like is this really delightful
really full
of joy so yeah i i think if you haven't
seen this yet uh this
if you're only gonna watch one oscar
movie this year um i would just hop on
amazon prime and stream this one it's uh
it's free from the same place you get
your toilet paper uh
okay let's go on to the next film let
chloe zhao's masterful direction
sweep across the pristine beauty of
america most of the time
for a documentary full of real people
plus a famous actor so that you'd
actually watch it
in this film that could be viewed as an
indictment of modern capitalism
or an endorsement for how sweet van life
can be i mean just look at that puppy
solid as a rock got an indoor stove for
hot chow ample storage
more counter space and no landlord
breathing down your neck
that's an lie to us living in a van down
by the river is
awesome bucket pissed
yeah i don't have too much to say about
nobody it's also the one i watched the
longest ago
um so it's been a while but um i guess
maybe the interesting not debate but but
balance that they have to strike
is similar to one of my favorites from a
few years ago uh
florida project where it's like are they
exploiting
is this poverty porn are they exploiting
uh poverty and making it romanticizing
it
um but at the same time i feel like with
the real people that they
involved in this movie it's like there
are people who just have
dropped not dropped out but have chosen
to go their own way through this life in
like a
less materialistic way and it's not
romantic you do have to poop in a bucket
but it also does afford you certain
freedoms that
the rest of us don't have yeah i think
um i think if this was a
if this was a documentary if this was a
like let's make a film about what it's
like to live in a van across america
i i think i would probably have some
more issues with it like in terms of
how amazon is depicted i also noticed
there's one
there's one moment where she's sleeping
fern is sleeping in her van and a
person just knocks on the window and she
gets like spooked for a moment and it
turns out they're friendly they're like
oh you can come inside and use the
bathroom
there's never any other scene where we
deal directly with the idea that this is
not
safe especially for a woman alone like
there's never a personal safety thing
and if this were a documentary you'd be
like
wait a minute like you're making it look
like this is totally like nobody's ever
going to bother you
and like you'd want to have a gun or
something you know like they
would never even engage with that but
because it's this woman's story and it's
about her life and what this
move means to her i don't i didn't get
too caught up in that i think it's an
emotional story and a narrative about
fern and the people she meets on the
road and what this life
means to her versus the alternative uh
i think that's where the heart of the
movie is it's really well done in terms
of that and
france mcdormand sort of taking you on
that on that sort of journey
and never and never seeming like it
never feels like it's in a
well we got to wrap this up or it's in a
cheesy way or like let's let her
we need to chase it we need a car chase
at the end there's no attempt to like
artificially
resolve and you almost feel like they
give you a sort of an out like well
maybe this will be what happens then
it's not and they sort of resist that
urge and let the character like kind of
go off into the horizon and
there's a there's a little bit of an air
of mystery and uh
yeah i i thought that was really well
done and yeah and yeah amazing
performance by uh
by francis and and clojow she can frame
herself a sweeping landscape man um yeah
and she's
really good she's she's made other films
with sort of amateur
actors and this movie as well has a
bunch of these people who really are
like sort of
modern nomads telling their stories to
camera or talking to fern about
themselves and
chloe's out amazing what captioning not
maybe or available does not have cancer
they added that to her story for the
movie really wow
because that was the highlight of the
film to me is like her just describing
important moments in her life that
weren't like the usual
money job career family things it was
like the right way
and that's true yeah the all her story
about the birds is true
like she's talking about her own life
but she was just going up north to go
see friends she wasn't going to like say
goodbye because she was dying of cancer
they
added that in his dramatic license which
i think is fine but
you know like that's a regular that's
not an actress that's a regular woman
who's just pretending and like that
very impressed yeah pretty phenomenal uh
filmmaking all around
um might be a little slow for some
people's tastes uh
i'm sure it helps to see it in a cinema
uh where
you know you can kind of take it all in
uh in widescreen
it's definitely the sort of thing you've
gotta sort of like meet you've gotta
meet the movie halfway it's not gonna
just come and be like all right
seven minutes there's a bomb we gotta go
you know like
you gotta kind of get into the rhythms
of this particular story yeah
uh but uh so curious to see how
uh eternals turns out um because i can't
see this mapping on to a marvel movie
at all but i can't wait to see how it
how it folds
unfolds it's this plus buff kumail
that's all you need and then that
together
i don't see how those two things fit
together but we'll see
anyways uh let's keep going
from the writer director who i still
haven't forgiven for being so mean to
lady die
comes the tale of a vigilante who uses
herself as man bait for sexual predators
so that she can give these creeps what
they truly deserve
a stern talking to careful next time you
go out now
in this film with parallels to another
story about someone in makeup who hates
society
oh no a lady joker with a powerful
message for girls
do not trust men if they were an
adorable comedic actor who peaked around
i want to see you the real you
and two mclovin don't kill bill for some
reason
all right pause well i think look with
the disclaimer and caveats that
i don't think lana and i can really even
comment on this one um
that's fine this is obviously a film
about
uh how women aren't believed and
supported as it pertains to
sexual assault uh in in this country in
society
and uh to that i have nothing to add yes
that is of course
a thing and an issue and a horrible
problem the film itself
i kept expecting there to be more
consequences for some of the men
that didn't come i thought this was like
the setup for an exploitation movie that
never
exploitation meaning like it's a revenge
thriller like she's getting
payback for all the people who wronged
her friend but they don't really get
payback ever yeah oh it seems to me like
all the worst things in the movie seem
to happen
to women and ultimately i feel like the
movie ends up coming down
on like the final lesson of the movie in
some ways i think is revenge is bad like
this is actually a
argument against revenge rather than an
argument against
i mean it obviously is taking on this
system and rape culture
and this idea that there aren't
consequences like men can sort of do
these horrible things and ruin lives
and move on it's it's encountering with
that idea but then it ultimately seems
to kind of push that to the side
and be like but revenge will eat you up
from inside and it's toxic and it will
ruin you and you can't lose yourself to
it
and it's like there's almost there's
like a double yeah yeah
there's a double twist at the end which
i won't spoil but it's like
i think it almost would have been more
powerful if it ended in the sense that
like
oh this is a broken system and one woman
can't change it um
and and the the male aggressive rape
culture
wins in the end but then there's a
double reversal on that that's like
aha actually and
and it's also relying on police to
save the day which is like isn't that
the point that they don't
say i don't know all these guys are rich
and connected and they're going to
you i left with the sense that well
there it'll be a nuisance but these guys
are still going to get away with it
um yeah i also there was one other thing
that was frustrating to me and it might
be a first time direct and look look for
a first-time director it's a
it's a good movie i'm not i'm not saying
this is like a piece of crap like
i would definitely want to see what
emerald fennel is going to do next and i
think this is like
an interesting provocative conversation
starting debut that's worth seeing
but another thing that felt a little
first movie to it about me was it's kind
of in this weird middle place between
our realistic world and then kind of a
heightened
larger than life fantasy world
and like sometimes you feel like you're
in one and then you shift to the other
and i think a more consistent
vision of that would have helped a lot
like if we're in a larger than life
world you could go a little bigger
with some of your creative choices and
get away with it if we're in a more
realistic world
you gotta keep things a little more
grounded i don't know if all the
sequences totally work you know you know
even the design sometimes it feels like
we're in like
tim burton candy-colored land and other
times we're just in a bar
yeah i i did think it was very inspired
uh casting choices to take these
uh icons of adorkable non-threatening
uh male male hood and and to kind of
flip them on
on your head uh it kind of
tips the hand for who's going to be evil
he's like oh i used to like that guy
uh oh yeah also i will say carrie
mulligan
and bo burton like the movie only kind
of works because you kind of
they they do a very good job of right
away making them charming as a couple
and you kind of want to get
them together like they're doing a good
enough job like
this could almost spin off into a
rom-com in some
segments like they're very good at that
like meet cute oh these two people like
each other
i feel like if they didn't nail that
through line nothing else would kind of
work yeah
but that to me like kind of dominated
the whole second half of the movie as it
turns into like a
like you said it's like it's an
anti-revenge revenge movie and that just
kind of
i couldn't quite wrap my head around
that aspect yeah i just don't know if
you could fully serve the
revenge's bad story while keeping the
important focus
on the men are bad story and it's like
no no let's let's do this movie about
men are bad
and then we can do revenge is bad later
right oh thank god danielle
i did it hi oh you're right you're just
in time i spread the need
two men were just about to finish
talking about the things they didn't
like about promising young women so
please
set it straight i think it was fair to
me
[Laughter]
um well promising a woman was a movie
that has been hyped at least for me for
a while like you would see the
commercials and all the women was like
oh what's uh
what's going on here with this thing and
so i feel like some of it suffered
because so many of us were waiting on it
and waiting to see what it was gonna be
about
um but it's hard to kind of live up to
that hype but for me
i i i guess i am
a hypocrite because i wanted to see more
violence
that was that was my thing was i was
like oh oh like you're
oh you every time you talk to them you
just like give them a stern talking to
you like you just like tell them like oh
like
this is bad and don't do this um
so yeah i wanted more violence that
sounds
terrible um but overall i overall i
enjoyed it i really liked it but
yeah no i needed i i wanted like just
straight up revenge tales
start stabbing dudes hey glad glad we're
all on the same page
well that's what we had just finished
saying is that it's a it's a revenge
movie that's against getting revenge on
people
and i would say like all all the
consequences the the real
consequences until the very end are all
visited on women
it's like the men get kind of get away
with it yeah
one guy says he's one guy says he's
really sorry so
and yeah i feel like at the end that's
like one of the easier self-defense
cases i mean i guess spoilers it's like
if you're cuffed to a bed and everybody
else is passed out and it's like this
person had
it was either you or them right uh
they'd be with the with their
high-priced lawyers they're gonna
i feel like they're gonna get away with
it so i don't love i don't know if the
movie
meant for us to think that or not but um
i think it was trying to give us a
satisfying well
the police fixed everything great yeah
and that that's the other thing for me
is like i
you can't really end your revenge movie
about how you had to take justice into
your own hands with like thank god the
cops are gonna save the day like
this movie exists because the cops did
because they did it the day before
remember
yeah anywho uh
i i guess that's it that's it uh
apologies in advance for
uh for that but let's keep going what
else we got
from the studio who brings you horror
films that turn out to be elaborate
metaphors about the notion of family or
whatever
comes a movie about being an asian
family in america
which was already pretty scary without
putting a babadook or whatever in it
returned to the 80s where despite what
stranger things in wonder woman say
was not covered in neon everywhere and
meet the yi family
a hearty band from california determined
to get out of the chicken sex and
business
in this stirring tale about how farming
is really effing hard
and marriage is even harder but at least
mountain dew is delicious
whose deliberate pace will give your
brain enough time to connect everything
back to the simpsons
check it out angry dad who loves food
sad mom who's worried all the time
devout christian neighbor grandparent
who's starting to lose it
a rebellious boy and a smart and
respectful sister and they all cram into
a beat up station wagon
hey maybe they should have tried growing
tobacco instead of korean vegetables
okay i'll stop
i'll stop veggie tales
uh paz this was um this is a lovely film
i certainly enjoyed uh i don't mean
lovely like oh it was lovely to watch
their marriage dissolve
and their farm burnout but but i did
enjoy
uh i enjoyed the ride and great great uh
performances it's such like a
to me it's gonna be tough to make the
case
i know stephen young's got like a lot of
buzz right now but to me it's such like
an ensemble movie like it's the family
dynamics it's the way like they're each
kind of playing off each other like if
there was a best
cast award i would give it to them um
because i liked like aspects of just
just the way they played off each other
so much
um but yeah uh i also won't
slam my foot on the table and do more
first cow ranting but i think if you're
gonna watch
uh if if you only can watch one uh
asian immigrant rural trying to eke out
uh
a living in uh uh the past in america
movie
i prefer first cow but that's neither
here nor there because
i'm because minari is really good too
what do you guys think of this
uh yeah it's really good i love watching
the relationships between the family
sorry i'm still like
shaken from dealing with that um comcast
nonsense but yeah i really like the
family i love the grandma
um just a great movie i really really
had fun watching it
uh yeah uh this this is definitely one
of my favorites of
the year for me i just i love uh i love
i love
when you get that you know you get
sucked into the the rhythms of this
this other you know way of living and
that this life uh
you know i i'm never gonna be a part of
an
immigrant family in you know the midwest
and the 80s
trying to start a korean vegetable farm
but i feel like even if it's simulated i
feel like i could now
i feel like i i get what that
perspective was about and it it it's you
know it's created this sense that
you know i have this insight into this
life and this way of living in this
experience that i would never
otherwise have it by the end when you
know
slightly more dramatic things start to
happen to the family
you you that's when you notice all the
groundwork that it's laid for an hour
and a half of getting you to know who
they are
and the rhythms of their life that they
don't have to do big things it's little
changes
that alert you to um there's there's a
scene where
uh the the wife goes to help her husband
clear vegetables out of this barn
and that simple act of let me help you
move a few boxes of these vegetables
communicate so much because we built up
all of this experience
with these characters and that's that's
uh you know that's the thing i think
only the the very best the most sort of
intimate
and thoughtful and and attentive and
observant movies really pull off
yeah it did show restraint and i think
uh uh
i think it came off um more positively
than what we were talking about with
nomad land but it's like
maybe just because of the uh the world
we live in today i kept waiting for like
okay here comes the angry racist lynch
mob to like
take him to to get this family out of
there like you you keep
expecting that to happen but the the
problems were so internal and it's like
farming is
hard enough as it is you didn't need to
have somebody with pitchforks
uh uh come chase them out of town so
yeah sometimes you want theater
sometimes you want to play
you know something a little quieter and
and it's it it sounds like
you know watching a movie about
water rights and about you know making
these kinds of deals
and about whether to move from the city
where you do chicken sexing to
this farm where you're gonna try this
new business like those don't sound like
exciting things like when you're
describing a fast and furious movie but
it's really
all in how you tell the story and how
you get us in it it is
there are moments that are funny in this
and there are moments that are dramatic
and
suspenseful yeah it's just it's it's you
know you have to kind of
just like i was saying for nomadland you
kind of have to meet the movie halfway
and give it time to like worm its way
into your brain
yeah but you're right it is like
it's not without tension and and
conflict and stuff like that but there
are
uh just the simple fact of being an
immigrant family in like rural arkansas
i think like you're expecting
things to happen that don't and then
they kind of have like chekhov's
uh heart condition with one of the
characters that i i feel like
doesn't fully go off although it's like
it's kind of used as a as a metaphor or
like a thematic
device right that's everything comes
through but not necessarily
in the most obvious way that is like
earmarked for you earlier i'm like look
some of these are supposed to be like
that and it's fine like
there's there's room for all kinds of
storytelling yeah it doesn't
it doesn't progress in the way that you
sort of expect that it's going yeah
um i will just one last time
say first cow first cow's really good i
also love first cow
it's it's kelly richard has a lot of
great movies and go back and watch them
you haven't seen that yet it is on my
list and now i feel like it's been put
on there five more times
good it's good all right let's keep
going
anthony hopkins gives the performance of
a lifetime
as an old man refusing help for the
dementia that's slowly eating away at
his mind
that's such a heartbreaking torturous
and cruel portrayal
of a legends final days there's no way
you actually watched it
new this year has been hard enough i'm
just going to watch this tick tock to
relax instead
never mind the downer
so yes anthony hopkins is the the least
likely tick-tock star
uh i think you could have predicted but
man he he gives you some heat
um i think also we've done this every
year uh in the oscars trailers we always
select one movie that we're like
you haven't seen this no it's not so
bleak it's like
you know what like i think it was lion
uh oh right yeah one year where it's
like
what movie was the if you if you say
you've seen this you're probably lying
was the
uh because i think that's the honest
truth about so much of the best picture
stuff is like people haven't seen all
the movies including the people who vote
on them
well this year that is usually true that
there's so many
nominees now that one or two inevitably
get by you but
this year especially because we weren't
all going to theaters
everybody was kind of watching different
stuff a lot of people are still getting
caught up on you know bridgerton
or whatever and haven't had a chance so
yeah i think this year in particular
there's movies that are like we've
gotten
way late in the season we're still like
the mauritanian that's not a real movie
like they're just they're they're kind
of still coming from outside and it's
like
hard to get your bearings yeah um
yeah this is real that's what jody
foster won for supporting actors for
uh well this movie was a was a it was
adapted from a play i believe
um and it it feels like that but in in
a way that i think adds to the film like
the claustrophobic-ness and like the
fact that you're just kind of
in it with this one guy for 99 of the
time like
you're right there with him with what
he's going through and it's a
uh not an experience i'd want to go
through again but i thought was really
moving
and um and messed with my head in a
in a way that tenet could only hope
uh yeah i mean it's it's it's it's
always nice when these great actors
there's so few
great roles for older
people i mean we would like you know
like you sort of get your peak rolls in
your like 20s
uh if you're a woman and then your 20s
through your like 40s if you're a man
and then uh like that that that's it we
don't know what else to do for you so
it's always nice when these great
legendary actors get to come back
and we at least have like the the one
final like
the dying mentor or the senile person
role
so they can sort of like go out you know
like the paul newman nobody's fool
move you know you get to like go out on
a high note and that that that
kind of feels like maybe this moment for
hopkins yeah
uh but yeah just another movie where
it's like oh
losing touch with reality just like oh
losing your hearing or
uh so many other films that
this year just gave you a real
empathetic gut punch and
and you leave it thinking wow i really
hope i
and the people i love never have to go
through that uh but but bravo
sir anthony um uh i don't think he'll
win this year
for bizarrely i don't know why why i
feel that way i just
uh i i think didn't this come out like
even later
or more inaccessible than the other ones
yeah this was this was the last one to
come out i believe it's still
it's still only like vod like i think
it's still like a twenty dollar
rental i had to do the 20 prime rental
to see it
wow look at you yeah yeah yeah so i
think um
i if i was if i were a a betting man
i would say uh chadwick boseman probably
would have
my my bet on who's gonna take it this
year
but uh you know yeah yeah so yeah asking
someone to pay
20 bucks to uh experience what it's like
to go through dementia is uh that's a
tall order but
if you're up for it um i i put it in
that it's nothing like requiem for a
dream but i'm just thinking of like
movies that i really enjoyed but never
want to see again it's
it's harrowing it's harrowing like
requiem for a tree yeah
so if you're feeling too good about
yourself check out the downer
um all right let's go star starring
all the things you actually decided to
watch this year
live action cartoons live action
cartoons we took way too seriously
all the new netflix shows all of the old
netflix shows
all of netflix until all that's left is
cooking and real estate shows
and he's not even eating a taco before
you're a taco virgin
you gotta eat a taco with me i gotta be
your first taco
okay okay find those two lighting sixty
dollars on fire
your cat is that your countdown
okay parties when you know they aren't
socially distancing because that's a
studio
apartment and i would love to have
company too but some of us are being
responsible and i haven't felt the warm
touch of another human being in months
because of this wasted year that's
flashing before my eyes
brad
those last two are uh danielle those are
true stories
uh yeah those are true stories uh i have
been watching my cats because they do
not as i've told people they don't f's
with me at all they do not like me i was
i was happy to be able to get that
little bit of it um so watching them
as they uh tear apart my house has been
a huge part of how i've spent this
and then yeah um neighbors having really
loud parties that i could hear and it's
like oh
i would also love to go to a party
wouldn't you it sounds great
uh brad is that a uh is that a made-up
name or is it that's amazing
are you calling them out okay i'm not
calling that a specific brand okay
fair enough well brad brads in general
you're on notice
um or whoever has brad like tendencies
watch out brad's
yeah coming for you well yes i'm glad we
could we could break the fourth wall
and uh and include your cat joe was said
that we didn't include uh his cat but
you know what joe don't right here no mo
so yeah really that's
the brakes man yeah sorry your cat does
not make it there was a sad email where
he accepted that fact
in the email
all right well now let's play my
favorite part
[Music]
i don't care what the academy says the
scene from money plane was the purest
moment of joy i had at the cinema all
year
whatever you want to wager on the money
plane has you covered you want to bet on
a dude
an alligator money plane
yeah that was my most liked uh do you
when they pitched
kelsey on money plate do you think they
even
sent a script at all or do you think
there was like we need you for two days
you be in and out one costume change
we'll we'll get you you know whatever
you want for for
dinner i like i don't even know i
literally feel like he like
landed put on the suit was like what am
i saying [ __ ] an alligator let's do
it you know like
there's no way he read that in advance
and was still like oh yeah i'm gonna do
this not a chance
maybe they just sent him his scene or
two
i'm just gonna say if he read a side
that was like
you want to bet on a dude [ __ ] an
alligator i think he's on the [ __ ] like
i'm [ __ ] frasier crane get me out
and you know we've got that our that
reboot or whatever that might be coming
up
so just trying to get some of that good
good money plane money in before he you
know he's busy
talking about doing stuff with
alligators
who i am we've got some exciting things
in the works here at honest trailers and
that might not be the last we see of
darius emmanuel
um the grouch there is aka the
rumble may not be the last we see of him
here on this show
um is there anything that we cut from
this episode let's let's play it
it must be and the guy from succession
doing an impression of cheech and chong
at the same time it's a tom collins i
know it's kind of a country club drink
but they're delicious
are there any american actors left to
play historical americans or at least
not sound like muppets
the socialist network trial by hippie
mostly judas featuring the black messiah
snitches get riches i got 99 problems
and a snitch is won
senior citizen k first responders
who's your own adventure
[Music]
the sound and the fury an actually quiet
place
cruisin usa i love that game
joke her she's not mad she's just
disappointed
get her to the geeks sympathy for lady
vengeance
farmers only ozark reactor
yun acres chicky chicky farm farm
sneeds feed and seed we are farmers
[Music]
[Laughter]
there we go good times um by the way if
you haven't subscribed at this point
uh please like and subscribe should
always mention that just in case this is
your first
time watching and you've just had to uh
sit here for almost an hour uh
now's the time to subscribe um let's go
to
some questions uh and comments from
viewers like yourselves uh larissa
m e har writes i think the whole point
of promising young women is that women
never get justice or revenge even so
yeah while the end was minimally
satisfying it kind of
beats the point or maybe kind of is the
point um yeah
i i think that that's uh that's
definitely a fair
reading of the film um yeah yeah
uh so uh
let's see uh evan j pretzel writes
what's your money plane
bet oh like what would i want to bet on
if i
could bet on anything complain yeah i
will say one disappointing thing about
the film money plane is that there
really
there is not a focus on outrageous bets
like you
think there is going to be they're
betting on like poker and stuff like
it's
you the lead in is very exciting and
dramatic yeah you can't promise me
gators and then give me card games
i'm not i was not excited about that
yeah
so yeah but i'm not hearing any money
playing bets out of you guys then
okay um we there there there's a guy on
twitter uh
iffy nwadway who frequently discusses
whether or not he could defeat
various wild animals
and i would i would i would want a money
plane to bet on that like
could he really take out the gorilla
that he thinks he could
yeah strength of strength i believe is
the official you gotta be able to take
it out strength
i i would be very curious to see him
apply some of this knowledge and
strategy
yeah okay all right um
yeah i guess i have just a limited
creative betting imagination because
it's like
uh i mean we could test the duck
horse-sized duck thing people
like asking questions all the time yeah
fine yeah you apply that
um but how would we get a horse-sized
duck yeah i don't know
money
you could just steal crypto from
anywhere you don't need to be on the
plane that's the whole point
um so uh uh so about i guess most of the
comments are about uh promising young
woman so uh yeah can you answer it so
that was all john right because i think
people think minari is a different voice
but that's all john doing everything oh
yes yes yeah he just changes up his tone
right yeah
there are yeah he can do a million
voices and that is the
his minari voice is uh if you actually
watch like prestige
drama trailers from from the 90s like
they kind of it's a little more nasally
um oh i thought oh yeah he's doing like
fox searchlight voice yes
exactly yeah exactly it's a real thing
uh uh also evan jay pretzer bring in the
heat uh
submitting my query now will the academy
be frank and give the best picture
ranked to mank for being about a film
industry prank
uh good good times uh jason georges
writes uh how do you decide the order of
the movies in the trailer
uh they're in the order in which they
were submitted and then you watch first
cut and then say
yeah maybe that one should go there um
just to kind of keep the voices separate
and the tone kind of uh mixing it up a
little bit
that's all there's no science to it um
pat mcgonna writes it's really strange
this year they went with eight best
picture noms when the last year had nine
i'm guessing they
really hated the five bloods now do you
think they
hated it or forgot about it because i
think it didn't
if it came out this last couple months i
think it would have been a shooting
i was really i don't know the answer to
this but i'm curious
what if netflix had just switched
chicago seven
and five bloods like they're both done
like what if they just released them in
opposite order like
i almost feel like the exact opposite
would have happened and like
we might have a bunch of nominations for
five bloods and
chicago seven would be that one from
early in the year like you remember that
eddie redmayne
aaron sorkin thing i'm surprised that
didn't get any nominations
yeah it feels like this i mean that's
one thing that always happens no matter
the year is that the further back you
are the more that people forget about
you and i think especially like
with everything that was going on when
the five bloods came out it's
it it's not easy to forget it's a great
movie but i do think that for the people
who are doing the voting
uh you know we're healing is that what
they say
hollywood is healing we're forgetting
about movies that didn't come out five
months ago
there you go um well okay and then i
hate to really
uh give this person all of the uh uh
all of the questions but evan j pretzel
just bring in the heat today
um is sorkin the creator most likely to
smell their own farts
i'm such a sucker i still love sorkin
like i still like a lot of it
i think it's just been like hammered
into my brain from all of my years of
watching west wing but i still really
enjoy it
that being said um i think his head is
so far up there that the farts never get
a chance to release
i mean who among us does has the
privilege of not smelling their own
farts i guess he means intentionally
like uh like yeah like
i feel like christopher nolan also
smells his own farts
but before he admits them he's like oh
that one's going to be a ribalden tree
and then farts
yeah i mean i think tarantino but he
like thinks it's funny it's like
check this one out
man john cassavetes farted like this all
right
machine gun mccain he references old
farts that he said
yeah classic farts that he's yeah lars
von trier maybe but he probably does it
to like
other people i think like yeah lars
matures making his actors smell
yeah yes matt dylan that one is for you
yeah um well that's the kind of
hard-hitting movie journalism you can
expect here on honest trailers
and australia's commentaries uh hope
you've had fun we've done a solid hour
um danielle thank you for for fighting
through
going through the fire uh uh of spectrum
slash comcast to to make it back with us
today
really it's because there's no universal
movies that we were talking about
they're just
angry pull the plug out taking it out
f9 should have gotten delayed yeah yeah
and thank you sorry we didn't love
trolls world tour
uh and thank you audience for sticking
with us um this is
always a fun one and we will do it again
next year should there be a next year
um and next week we're doing uh another
multiple film honest trailer uh that
happens to coincide with a
oncoming holiday so we hope you enjoy
that one too
uh we'll be back next week for more
australia's commentaries thanks for
watching
[Music]
bye
you